a district attorney in Santa Fe New
Mexico is expected to announce today
whether charges will be brought in the
deadly 2021 shooting on the set of the
film rust actor Alec Baldwin is among
those who could be charged he was
holding the gun that went off killing
cinematographer Helena Hutchins Baldwin
has described that day as a tragic
accident and denies doing anything wrong
Chris Van Cleef has the story
someone is responsible for what happened
and I can't say who that is but I know
it's not me in an exclusive interview
with ABC news anchor George
Stephanopoulos in December of 2021 Alec
Baldwin insisted he had no idea how a
live bullet ended up in the revolver he
was holding on the set of the unfinished
film rust I would never point a gun to
anyone to pull a trigger but according
to Santa fe's district attorney Baldwin
and up to three crew members could
possibly face charges in the death of
cinematographer Helena Hutchins during
an October 2021 rehearsal Baldwin was
holding the prop gun when it discharged
around killing Hutchins and injuring
director Joel Souza I think it's really
unlikely that Alec Baldwin will be
charged trial attorney Rachel fazay
tells CBS mornings she believes it's
those in charge of safety on the set
that are in the most legal Jeopardy
including the film's armorer Hannah
Gutierrez read what the investigators
and the prosecutors have been evaluating
for the last 14 months is who knew the
risks on the set that relate to Serious
injury or death as the person in charge
of overseeing all weapons on set
Gutierrez read has acknowledged she
loaded the prop gun that day but her
attorney says she did not place a live
bullet in the gun today's decision comes
just three months after Baldwin and his
fellow producers reached a settlement
with Hutchins family the deal will allow
production to resume sometime this month
Jose says that settlement could work in
Baldwin's favor if the victim's family
is willing to settle or perhaps forgive
the actions of Alec Baldwin than maybe
the prosecutor tutors will think to
themselves well maybe we shouldn't
continue to Drudge it up for CBS
mornings I'm Chris Van Cleave in Santa
Fe New Mexico
it's still a heartbreaking tragic story
for everybody involved in doesn't get
any easier and I keep thinking about
Elena Hutchins left behind a husband and
a very young boy yeah she's a young
artist and a young mother yeah